in the last couple of weeks you have
probably heard me use the term
management by optics and i've used this
term to refer to the handling of
coronavirus by donald trump and the
administration and
i've also applied it to mike pence and
donald trump's
non-use of masks during recent public
appearances
and there's now a new report from the
associated press excellent article
which says that indeed according to
people close to trump
not authorized to speak about this trump
is refusing to wear a mask in public
because number one he believes he would
look
ridiculous wearing one and number two
and this is the more interesting piece
he believes it'll hurt his chances at
being re-elected because of the message
that wearing a mask would send and we'll
get to that report
in a second so one example of management
by optics is
the case numbers and the death numbers
are a disaster uh we've been
in these sort of rolling patchworks of
stay-at-home orders now for close to two
months
and the numbers are terrible every day
we're finding around 25 000 new cases of
coronavirus despite
testing not having increased that that
dramatically
uh or much at all over the last half
month or so we
had spikes once again this week to 2500
deaths on
multiple days during the week so the way
that trump
is managing by optics is simply
not talking about deaths and cases
manage the optics which are
say that we won talk about these heroic
warriors which are
the americans that trump is talking
about uh
talk about how we are now getting to
reopen the economy and
30 states or whatever the number they
claim is are starting to reopen
their state economies mike pence didn't
wear a mask
when he went to the mayo clinic recently
and
he was excoriated for it ended up
wearing a mask on his next visit
out but again it's the optics of if you
say things are going really well
if you say we're past the peak if you
say we've won if you say we are now in
the recovery mode
you certainly can't be seen wearing a
mask for the first time in public that
would
imply things are not as good as you
claim they are
so that gets us to donald trump earlier
this week donald trump flew out to
arizona we covered it
covered some of his live events there he
went
literally to a mask factory a factory uh
repurposed facility of honeywell where
they are
making masks and they have in you know
right on the wall
on a tv it says mandatory masks keep a
mask on at all times
trump didn't wear a mask and once once
again we knew we suspected
based on what we know about trump that
this is more management by optics trump
wearing a mask when he says we've
basically won
we're past it we're reopening it's all
great he succeeded at keeping the death
toll
well below 2 million it doesn't send the
right signal and indeed that's exactly
what the new report says trump
believes that if he was seen wearing a
mask it would hurt his chances of
reelection it would make him look
ridiculous trump has said to advisers
that wearing a mask would quote
send the wrong message and it would make
him seem
preoccupied with health i
for me it would be good i would love to
see trump preoccupied
with health that's the problem the
problem is he seems not to care about
health
trump also has told confidance according
to the same associated press report
that he fears he would look ridiculous
in a mask
and that the image of him wearing a mask
would be used in negative ads
against him understand the insanity of
that
the mask has become a proxy
political statement at this point in
time if you wear a mask it means you
believe this is serious you believe
things are bad
you believe people should be scared not
wearing a mask means
you don't trust these hoaxer governors
or everything's fine or the economy will
soon be open
and people will soon or have already
stopped dying
from coronavirus it's now a political
statement something that
is just supposed to be a matter of
science just to be supposed to be a
matter of health
the masks are worn for very empirical
demonstrable reasons now they have
become
political calculations and i hate to
tell you
maybe trump is making the right
calculation for his
followers seeing trump wear a mask to
somebody like me
would say trump understands the science
trump trusts the experts trump cares
about other people
but trump is the guy who looked directly
at a solar eclipse
and he's making the equivalent choice
here with the masks now
i i have to tell you the looking
ridiculous thing
this is not a show that focuses on
things like the physical appearance of
our elected officials
but trump saying the mask will make me
look ridiculous
trump has been going around with a
lunatic looking fake tan for years
he walks around in these oversized suits
very often
even if we grant the concern about
looking ridiculous with the mask and how
that might affect his supporters or
whatever
trump regularly looks ridiculous and so
that
is also sort of a complicated thing to
get a sense of but it's not the most
important thing
the most important thing here is the
continued management by
optics and the really sad reality
that when it comes to his followers he
may be right his followers may see him
wearing a mask
and actually be turned off by it and
unfortunately
when trump's followers see him not
wearing a mask
it encourages them not to wear one which
leads to viral spread
which leads to cases which leads to
deaths it's
very very ugly management by optics
extraordinarily dangerous and we're
seeing that in action
look at the case numbers in these states
look at what's happening in texas
look at what's happening in georgia
arizona states that are reopening early
it's not good and it's getting worse and
now donald trump is proactively saying
now i'm not going to be seen with a mask
that'll be used in ads this episode is
sponsored by
bluechew one of the things i make a
priority on the show
is not to perpetuate stigma for things
that don't deserve it we've talked about
mental health we've talked about many
things where we should all just be
respectful adults period and we would be
better off
and blue chew can increase performance
and give you that extra confidence you
may be looking for bluetooth.com
blue like the color blue is the first
chewable
with the same fda approved ingredient as
in
viagra and cialis it can be taken day or
night even on a full stomach since it's
chewable
it works twice as fast as a pill
whenever the opportunity arises
blue chew is prescribed online by
licensed
doctors you don't have to go to a
doctor's office you don't have to wait
in line at a pharmacy it ships right to
your door
in a discrete package they're made in
the usa and since blue chew prepares and
ships direct
it's cheaper than a pharmacy and best of
all
no more awkwardness we've got a special
deal for our viewers and listeners go to
bluetooth.com
get your first shipment free when you
use our promo code pacman that's
n p-a-k-m-a-n just five dollars shipping
that's b l ue
chew.com promo code pacman to try it
totally free
bluechu is the better cheaper faster
choice
and we thank them for sponsoring the
david pakman show